[Music]
all right welcome back
so this is i think one of my favorite uh
lectures in the series on complex
analysis
because we are finally going to start
putting together pieces we've learned
about analytic functions
complex contour integrals
and this is one of the pieces that's
going to be the most useful in deriving
the cauchy integral formula and some of
the most fundamental results in complex
analysis
so i'm going to jump in
we are talking about analytic functions
and how you know we can do derivatives
and calculus and integrals in the
complex plane with these functions
and we've already seen before that all
polynomials
are analytic all polynomials
all polynomials and all convergent power
series and uh let's say all
uh convergent
uh convergent let's say uh
taylor series all convergent taylor
series
uh our convergent all convergent taylor
series are analytic within their radius
of convergence these are all
are all
analytic
uh inside
the radius
of convergence this is just a statement
of a um
a property we've talked about before all
polynomials z squared z cubed z to the
fourth z squared plus z cubed things
like that all polynomials in a complex
variable z
are analytic everywhere in the entire
complex plane
and all convergent taylor series are
analytic inside their radius of
convergence so if i have a taylor series
you know a function like e to the z
cosine z sine of z those are convergent
everywhere so they're analytic
everywhere other functions um
you know like logarithm on its principle
you know branch
cut
is has a convergent taylor series away
from the origin so it would be analytic
away from the origin things like that
this is a fairly normal
statement
and functions with singularities are not
analytic at the singularities so
functions
uh
with singularities
are not
analytic
at the singularities at the
singularities
[Music]
but they might have nice properties of
how they integrate anyway that's what
i'm going to show you today is that even
though these functions are not analytic
many many many non-analytic functions
still have very simple contour integrals
around them that equal zero so that's
what we'll see today so a good example
of this is
as an example
if we have
z
minus some point a if i just so
what i'm going to talk about normally
i'm talking about polynomials z to the n
here i'm going to center that polynomial
at some base point a you know so that
this taylor series is not just always
expanded about z equals zero but we're
expanding about some base point z equals
a
and if i take z minus a to the nth power
this is
let's say analytic
for
you know n equals 0 1 2
dot for power positive integers but it's
non-analytic
for
negative powers n equals minus 1 minus 2
minus 3 and so on okay so we know that
this function if i take you know 1 over
z minus a or 1 over z minus a squared
that's singular at z equals a so it's
specifically not analytic at
z equals a
for
all of these
negative integers n
but what i claim is that for all n even
negative ones except for n equals
negative one this still has a pretty
nice clean uh
integral expression there's still easy
things we can do even if we integrate
around this singular point z equals a
and this will be useful
again i'm going to give you a teaser i
think it's really important for you to
know where stuff is going especially
when it seems esoteric
is that you know taylor series are
expansions uh you know
let's say um
a taylor series would be like f of z
equals
um
you know a sum of coefficients
z minus a to the power n
where n equals 0 to infinity it's kind
of this positive expansion of you know z
minus a plus z minus a squared plus z
minus a cubed fourth fifth sixth all
weighted by these coefficients um that's
you know like how we get the taylor
series for e to the z or cosine of z or
sine of z this is a taylor series
uh taylor series but there are weird
functions again the complex plane is is
a wilderness
of of interesting complex functions
there are other expansions called
laurent series
laurent uh it was laurent or laurent
laurent
series i guess it's probably a french
name
where now this f of z
is not just a sum of only positive
powers of z minus a to the n but we
actually have to sum overall
uh
negative you know powers negative
infinity to positive infinity
of c n z minus a
to the n so i don't just have positive
powers of z minus a i also have to add
up negative powers it's kind of a
two-sided taylor series not just
positive exponents but negative
exponents as well and when i integrate
these exotic functions in closed orbits
around the point a
almost all of the terms are going to
drop out except for this n equals minus
one which is called the residue
the real sticky icky of this laurent
series
so
functions like e to the minus 1 over z
weird functions oh that pen is disaster
e to the minus 1 over
z functions like that would need this
two-sided taylor series this laurent
series and to do interesting contour
integrals of that i will need to use the
property i'm about to show you good
all polynomials and convergent taylor
series are analytic within their radius
of convergence
um monomials like z minus a to the power
n i guess this is a polynomial a
polynomial z minus a to the power n is
analytic for positive n for positive
integer n and it's non-analytic for
negative integer n
at the singularity point z equals a and
if i draw a little picture of this uh
it'll make you know pretty clear sense
that basically at uh let's say i'm in my
complex plane here i'm in my complex
plane and this is my point
a
and i'm looking at z at this this point
basically you know kind of
this thing goes to you know either
infinity or minus infinity at that point
a it's a singular point where uh one
over
one over z minus a has infinite
magnitude at z equals a it kind of blows
up okay weird stuff happens it's
singular it's non-analytic
so now what i'm going to show is that
even though you have those weird
non-analytic functions for n equals
minus 2 minus 3 minus 4 minus 5
most of their integrals are actually
quite simple and it's only the n equals
minus 1 case that's at all weird
so how do i want to do this
so i'm going to say
even though they're non-analytic their
integrals have nice properties
so case 1
is
all of the n
except n equals one
so case one is n equals plus one plus
two three four dot dot dot or minus two
minus 3 minus 4 dot dot dot everything
except for the n equals 1 case which is
really really special
the residue
we're going to call it
and in case 1 we basically have that the
integral
and we're talking about the integral of
a closed contour
we have this this point a
that is going to be singular it is
non-analytic at this point a
and we are talking about a closed
contour c
that goes around that non-analytic point
a
this closed contour c
of
z minus a
to the power n
dz this is actually pretty simple
integral of z minus a to the power n is
probably something like z minus a to the
power n plus one
z minus a to the power n plus one
divided by n plus one
and i get to evaluate this
uh you know at whatever this let's say
that it starts at z naught and it goes
around in this closed contour c
uh i basically would evaluate this thing
at
uh you know at those those boundaries of
of that function
uh so z minus a to the n plus one over n
plus one evaluated at uh z naught and z
naught
equals zero so this is going to require
a little bit of thinking of why this is
true
when we are integrating this function
around
it essentially comes
down to the fact it's kind of like
related to that uh fundamental integral
theorem of integral complex uh functions
is that because the z minus a to the n
it does actually have a closed form
definite integral z minus a to the power
n plus one and that
that doesn't change when i go around in
a closed orbit around a it's the same
point
uh even if i you know
increase the phase angle or change it or
whatever it's the same point when i go
from you know z zero to
zero zero that's equal to 0.
case 2
i think you'll understand why case 1 is
simple when i show you case 2. case 2
is the n equals minus 1 case and this is
the only one that's different
in this case if i write down the contour
integral of z minus a to the minus one
power
which is one over z minus a dz
we know that the integral of one over z
is log of z similarly the integral of z
minus eight to the minus 1 power
is
log
of z minus a
now again evaluated
and i want to be really careful here
evaluated remember our complex logarithm
is multi-valued
our complex logarithm
log
of z
equals
the real value log of the radius of z
plus i times the principal angle of the
variable z
plus 2
pi
2 pi n
and so if i look at the phase v the real
part sorry the imaginary part v the
phase of that that complex logarithm
we've seen this in the previous lectures
remember how i always say that we're
going up this spiral staircase in the
complex logarithm i start at some
principal angle
theta
p
and as i go this is the x
y plane we're doing this integral in the
x
y plane and let's say this is the origin
a equals zero here for the for the
logarithm case or let's say this is the
point
uh a which is the origin of log z minus
a
if i go around
in a circle if i go around one
counterclockwise loop i have gone up one
level
of uh
when i go up
one level of this uh this spiral
staircase i have added two pi
i to the phase v so i have gone up
an amount to
pi
i so if i look at this from the top down
in the x y plane in the the complex
plane and i do a closed orbit around the
singular point here the which in the
case of logarithm is the origin if i do
a closed orbit around that singular
point
the phase angle increases it goes up the
spiral staircase one level and i've
added a two pi i because i've added two
pi i to the phase angle of my z variable
i've added a 2 pi i here
and so this is we think of this as you
know
let's say
z 0 is where we start i should write z 0
is where we start
and z1 is where we end and they are
different points for the complex
logarithm this is z one
and z one is two pi i bigger than z zero
so if i evaluate this at z one minus z
zero this equals two pi
i
i'm going to um
show you this again i'm going to derive
two different ways why this is two pi i
i'm just kind of giving you a little bit
of a teaser here so if that if that was
a little bit
counter-intuitive or confusing i'm going
to show you this two ways how this is
true again like formally
but what we see here is that if i you
know do this integral of z minus a to
the power n
for n not equal to minus 1 then this
definite integral um
this is essentially because z minus a to
the power n is single valued even for
negative n for positive n and for
negative n this is single valued and so
even if i go around in that loop i don't
gain any phase there's no other values
for me to climb to so that equals zero
on this closed loop but in this very
special case of n equals 1 if i
integrate
1 over z minus a in a closed loop around
a
then i get the logarithm of z minus a
and i can kind of shift everything to
the origin
so that it's a little bit easier to
picture so i'm integrating around that
singular point a
if i go in a closed orbit in the in the
z plane
i add 2 pi i of phase to this logarithm
my logarithm climbs up 2 pi i
for every full rotation i do in the z
plane so this adds up to 2 pi i
so all of these closed integrals are
still 0 even though we're integrating
around a point where they're
non-analytic for negative n
and this is the only uh case one over z
minus a where if i integrate a closed
loop over that non-analytic point a i
get an honest-to-goodness non-zero uh
contouring i get this two pi i
this is super super important and
complex variables this is uh
you know called the residue so if i take
my laurent series
if i have a function f of z that is
defined by a laurent laurent series
and i take
the uh
the integral of this laurent series
over a contour c that encloses the
singular point a
of f of z that's divided with this
two-sided laurent series
i can break it up into an integral of
every single term in that series you
know z minus a
to the power 1 to the power 2 to the
power 3 to the power minus 2 minus 3
minus 4. and all of those closed
integrals equal zero except the n equals
one integral so this
equals the closed orbit integral
of c minus one
z minus a
to the minus 1 power dz and that's why
this constant coefficient outside of
that n equals minus 1 case is called the
residue
as i like to say the the real sticky
icky residue the residue
and it's the only one you need to keep
track of if you're doing those closed
orbits so this would equal
c minus 1 2 pi
i
that's really really important property
in complex functions that you can take
this nasty gnarly laurent series with
like an infinite number of
you know positive powers and negative
powers and if i'm integrating around
closed loops that include that singular
point
uh the only the only term that actually
matters is the n equals minus one term
that contributes to a non-zero integral
very very important okay good
uh
what else am i going to show you yeah
now i want to show you again i'm going
to show you why this two pi i
solution
is
the way it is and i'm going to do it two
ways so i'm going to erase this half of
the board real quick and i'm going to
you know solve this integral kind of two
different ways to give you some real
intuition that this is in fact two pi i
so be right back
okay so i want to just kind of reconfirm
why this case two is non-zero when i
integrate
z minus a to the negative 1 power and a
closed contour around the point a
because i get this logarithm because it
adds 2 pi i of phase every time i go
around
a closed orbit in the z plane so i think
there's kind of two approaches the first
approach
is i'm literally going to
and this is you know let's say that this
is my point a i'm just going to put a at
the origin to make my life way easier
sorry my screen's getting cut off and i
have any contour i like
c this is my contour c and the
convention is that it's counterclockwise
remember how in the last lecture we use
the koshi gorsa theorem so that we can
continuously deform these away from the
singular point a
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
continuously deform this into a circle
of radius r this is going to be a circle
of radius
r and i'm going to keep r equal to a
constant that's really important i'm
going to have a circle of radius r and
now i'm just integrating this thing from
theta equals 0 to 2 pi that's going to
be way way easier for us to do
uh so
z equals uh z minus a
equals r e to the i theta
and dz the infinitesimal element i'm
going to integrate with respect to
is equal to r is a constant so there's
no kind of dr term so it's just
i
r e to the i
theta d theta that's what dz is if i
hold r constant
so that's super important
and now um what i'm going to do is i'm
going to do this integral here i'm going
to show that the integral
uh the integral over my closed contour
let's call this
c uh right i deformed it into this this
contour
of z minus a to the negative one power d
z
i'm going to now uh kind of write both
of these terms here
and what am i going to get
z minus a
over it's 1 over z minus a so it's 1
over this so it's
z minus a to the negative 1 power
is
z minus a to the negative 1 so it's 1
over all of this stuff r e to the i
theta
and it's dz over that so it's i r
e to the i theta
d theta and now i'm integrating from
theta equals 0 to 2
pi i'm going to start at 0 and i'm going
to go around to 2 pi okay that's we just
so so essentially what i'm trying to do
is i'm trying to turn this into a simple
integral kind of in terms of just theta
or going around theta so you can really
see that there is an honest-to-goodness
increase in theta
um okay so this is the expression here
and what do i need to do
well this is like almost trivial
r e to the i theta divided by r e to the
i theta all i have is this little i term
here maybe i'll switch colors
this equals
the integral from 0 to 2 pi
of i
d theta
and that equals 2 pi
i
so that's you know like almost a trivial
way of demonstrating that this integral
for n equals minus 1 equals 2 pi i we
didn't even use the fact that it's a
logarithm i just deformed it to assert
my contour to a circle of constant
radius
i wrote my z minus a in you know polar
coordinates and my dz and polar
coordinates and we just computed the
integral and we found that honest to
goodness when we go around that closed
radius
constant circle from 0 to 2 pi we pick
up 2 pi i of phase angle that's
intuitively what we expected because of
this logarithm because this logarithm is
multiple valued and when i go around
in in the z plane when i when i go
around in the z plane i add 2 pi i to
the phase angle of my logarithm as as i
see here
so
this is kind of an alternative way
of showing that this integral is equal
to two pi i
and of course the the first way uh is to
actually just you know say that the
integral of one over z minus a is
logarithm of z minus a and use this
formula for the logarithm of yeah i mean
really i should do
um this is log of z minus a
where again z minus a equals r e to the
i theta
i'm being a little bit glib here i'm
assuming that we're just centered at z
equals a i'm shifting my coordinate
system so you know a is kind of the
origin but i plug in my logarithm and i
see that as i go around in a closed
orbit around this point as i increase
theta from from theta principle to
starting theta to theta principle plus 2
pi i add a 2 pi i
of a phase angle so this is two
different ways of seeing that when i do
this integral i pick up a 2 pi i only
for the n equals minus 1 case
i think it'd be really good for you
actually to take this case for all of
the other n
and maybe write it in r equals i theta
polar coordinates and actually show
because these are all single valued
functions they're not multi-valued like
this even for n equals minus two minus
three minus four all the positive ones
these are single valued functions so
when i write my function like this
uh and i you know
do that that integral
i it all adds up to zero so that's
actually a really good homework i think
i'm going to assign that for my students
is to like literally do this
deform my contour into a circle of
constant radius
and then do this integral but for all of
these other n cases and confirm for
yourself that they really do add up to
zero that's really going to strengthen
your intuition for these complex numbers
and so this gives us one of the most
pivotal results in all of complex
analysis
is that the closed contour
of z minus a to the power n as long as
this closed contour includes that point
a
dz
equals
zero
for all n that's not equal to negative
one and it equals two pi i for n equal
to minus one and again we can use this
when we are integrating up uh those
laurent series those two-sided taylor
series on a closed orbit containing the
point they're expanded about the only uh
coefficient i need to keep track of is
that n minus one coefficient the
coefficient of the one over z minus a
term called the residue okay and this is
kind of the residue theorem uh it's
related to the residue theorem if you
like
very very very important property and
complex
analysis complex functions and we're
going to use this
in the cauchy integral formula that's
coming up next all right stay tuned